henry kissinger is a titan of american
politics
we will not be blackmailed
having served as secretary of state and
national security advisor
during the nixon and ford
administrations
he pioneered the de taunt period of
easing tensions with the soviet union
during the cold war
and in 1972 coordinated a breakthrough
summit in china
paving the way for formal diplomatic
relations between the two countries
dr kissinger spoke to the economist asks
podcast
about the current standoff between
america and china
and what the biden administration needs
to do to avert
rising tension henry kissinger welcome
to the economist asks
pleasure to be here you've said recently
that the world
is heading back to a time of great
conflicts potential superpower
conflicts tensions between the us
and china have brought that into the
foreground
do you think that that threat has got
markedly
greater of late dialogue between china
and the united states has taken on
increasingly confrontational character
and the
issues one side
alleges we allege that the chinese are
aiming for
global hegemony the chinese
believe that we are intervening in
their domestic affairs with
issues defined like this
every additional issue that might emerge
makes it uh more and more difficult to
come to an
understanding which i believe
in the light of the capacities of the
two countries
and the technological evolution
uh i believe that some agreement on
principle between the two sides
it's essential and it will have to
happen
and it will happen sooner or later when
you say in
in principle i'm i'm interested what
might that look like
what would an agreement a new
pacs between america and china look like
i think the minimum understanding that
is required
is that the two sides exclude a
high-tech war
between each other and secondly
that they exercise restraint
in their relations with each other but
also in relations with the rest of the
world
and on that basis gentleman can take up
individual
issues as they arise
and when you imagine this
steps that you feel need to be taken on
both sides
how do you assess the pivot of president
biden's
foreign policy after a relatively short
time
in the white house what do you think of
the thrust of
his approach president biden has
assembled
a very competent team and
they are in the preliminary phase of
coming to internal conclusions and in
that sort of a feeling out process
with the chinese as to what a dialogue
between china and the united states
might look like i think it is
an improved tone over his predecessor
and fundamentally
a confrontation which challenges the
basic structure of either side
must be avoided i start from that
principle
and we are heading into
a dialogue i believe
that will allow this to happen you
believe
if i understand you correctly that
president biden is interested
in opening dialogue with china and yet
his public pronouncements
on trade on human rights
on the relationship in general have been
pretty tough
is there a continuity perhaps with
donald trump on that
score do you see this as a new era biden
is attempting to balance its domestic
pressures
against his international necessities
within the united states right now china
as a thread has become a another
commonplace view and it's probably
the case that the opposition party
that the republicans are probably
waiting
for some opportunity
to demonstrate that brighton is soft
on chinese communists so
he is seemingly attempting to navigate
between these conflicting
uh requirements to
achieve some definition of the
international order
on which we in china agree and the
necessity of
maintaining a domestic cohesion
behind foreign policy that seems to be
the basic
issue it's 50 years ago i think since
you were
engaging with china when you famously
went to china and broke that long
standoff
with beijing you have strongly advocated
working with china ever since
i'm going to say that the some of the
evidence doesn't seem
entirely to be running towards
vindicating
your hopes of of that time a few
examples would be
china's actions including record numbers
of
chinese jets in taiwanese airspace the
bearing down on
hong kong and extinguishing of freedoms
legal and political there
human rights abuses xinjiang zhang the
rules-based order
that maintains global stability does not
seem to be applying
very clearly to china at the moment
doesn't this
merit a harder line i have never
advanced to view that coexistence with
china will lead to a democratization of
china
i look at china as a long historical
evolution operating by partly by
confusion
as well as by marxist principles which
include
a an invocation for their country
for the highest standard of performance
the question is whether a country
performing at that level
and the united states can coexist
creatively because for the united states
we have never
in our history encountered a country of
that magnitude
it's likely to have that magnitude for
an indefinite period of time
and is it possible to have
coexistence between a democratic country
and a combination confusion mark this
country
i believe it's necessary i also believe
it's attainable
but i don't believe it's automatic so
we have to define the issues henry
kissinger
thank you very much indeed for joining
us you can listen to the full
interview in our podcast the economist
asks every week
we talk to a high profile figure click
the link opposite
to find this episode and thanks for
watching
you